foreign
okay well the first sort of question if
you like I suppose it's a
it's a historic question is it possible
um to provide a true account of the
ultimate bits that make up the Universe
I know you all sort of Ruby you're sort
of anti the sort of reductionist idea
why are we so obsessed with bits anyway
but I want to ask can we can we get to
the to the the turtle foundations I
suppose you mentioned vibrating strings
you know that's kind of where we are at
the moment that's the sort of theory
does your for good reason String Theory
Paul perhaps you can just tell us
perhaps where we are at the moment yes
uh and where we can go can we get it can
we cut it even smaller I want to take
say two things the first is to sort of
arrive at a compromise because
reductionism gets a bad press and I'm a
fan of reductionism by the way I'm going
to put my cards on the table right
um and uh and it's certainly true you
learn a lot by Smashing things to bits
and seeing how they're put together
um and it's been immensely successful
and uh and Rupert is quite bright it
does cost a lot of money to build
particle accelerators
um but we've discovered new particles
that couldn't be found any other way uh
there's a sort of semi understanding of
what's going on among all those little
bits and pieces but we're a long way
from a complete understanding but
obviously it's productive and so it's a
very effective way of uh having a first
go at understanding the world but it's
absolutely not the whole story and it
even if you figured out all of the
fundamental particles it wouldn't tell
you how I'm likely to vote in the next
election or anything of that sort and so
you know I completely agree that there's
the layer upon layer of emergent uh
phenomena that require their own uh laws
and principles that should be consistent
with but not reducible to those down to
the bottom level absolutely agree I
think there's a middle position it's not
hopeless it's not one or the other we
need both where are we at well that that
could be a very long conversation but uh
the theoretical physics Community is
enthrall of something called String
Theory or sometimes M Theory the idea
being that unlike Democritus who wanted
little particles everything made out of
little particles the ideas they're made
out of little strings little Loops of
strings that wriggle around and I'd say
wriggling different ways this is
perceived by us on a bigger scale as
different types of particle uh and the
so the idea is is only one or maybe a
few types of string so the fundamental
entity would be this string and out of
it would come not just the particles of
matter but the particles that convey the
fundamental forces of nature like
electromagnetism of gravitation and so
on would all be in that mix and so if
you could get this to work uh you'd have
a super duper equation you could wear on
your T-shirt and it would capture in a
succinct mathematical way or natural
phenomena particles forces and
everything it's wonderful some of my
colleagues have wasted their whole lives
actually uh it's working working in this
area but they remain upbeat that they
will get there eventually but you know
to decades long quests so it's just not
done yet string theory is going to where
we are at the moment I mean I notice
they're actually they're turning on the
light they're cranking up the LHC the
large highlights a long way from Street
another run so the big news a few years
ago was and I mentioned the the Higgs
both on the Higgs particle that sort of
gives particles Mass
um what are they gonna what are we
looking for now are we looking for are
we looking for string we're going to see
like a wiggly worm
at the risk of dominating the
conversation because otherwise my wife
will stand up okay very just very just
very very quick and they're going to
come on to classification uh the uh what
was the question again
actually we're while we're on the
subject of t-shirts and in the CERN gift
shop they sell the t-shirts with the the
standard model of the pathophysics on it
yes it's the standard model is the term
that we need to introduce yeah and I'm
sort of interested from a sort of
philosophical point of view because
where does philosophy come into all this
because basically aren't we just looking
closer and closer what what a philosophy
philosophers got to talk to us about
well there's a couple of things in kind
of recent developments where I think
philosophy uh is brought to bear on it
so one uh Paul was saying that some of
his colleagues have wasted time on swing
through one of the reasons people worry
about string theory is because if we
don't have any uh hope of any empirical
uh justification uh then people worry
that's not very scientific so the the
kind of Hallmark of science is often
meant to be that it's possible to
falsify your theories show that they
were wrong and if there's no way of
getting any empirical evidence for um
String Theory uh then people worry that
that's it's not on a safe fitting and
this is can I just just yeah can you
just expand a bit on this idea of
falsification for those who aren't
familiar with where it comes from
because I think it's a really important
term right so uh falsification goes back
to the philosophy of science uh popper
uh who was at the lse uh his idea was
the thing that really tells the
difference between uh science and
pseudoscience uh is whether you can
falsify your theory can you do an
experiment and show that in fact it
could have been wrong so it's not about
proving you're correct it's actually
seeing it if you pull your theory apart
and just right if there was no possible
way of disproving it
um say every time you had some evidence
it didn't look like it quite fitted with
your theory you just came up with
another kind of ad hoc modification
then that wouldn't count as being a
scientific theory and where are we with
string theories are people accusing that
of being unfalsifiable it's not I guess
It's Tricky is
it's not unfalsifiable in principle it
just looks very difficult yeah the the
problem is you've got you've talked
about Large Hadron Collider if you
really wanted to pull the strings apart
so to speak you can poke around you'd
need to go 20 orders of magnitude
greater in energy 20 orders of magnitude
it's one followed by 20 zeros above the
Large Hadron Collider but we know that
what the Large Hadron Collider has to
answer your previous question has found
is incomplete because there's something
called the standard model of particle
physics which is our best understanding
of the
electromagnetic uh weak and strong
nuclear forces and it's worked
brilliantly for decades but it can't
explain why neutrinos have mass or what
the dark matter is in the universe and a
bunch of other stuff we know there's
physics beyond the standard model and
the hope with the revamped Large Hadron
colliders we get a glimpse of what that
physics might be maybe by even producing
a an a new particle
Rupert you'll I I get the sense you're
really anti you you said you're sort of
anti this reductionist view of the
Universe I don't think physicists would
disagree with you when you talk about
it's it's more than that why are you so
anti it what why and why are you so anti
the the I don't say anti the scientific
method because you're not but what but
your auntie how science has done you
mentioned sort of oh they throw lots of
money at this thing and this is this
isn't the only game in town and I'm
wondering where that comes from
I think it's partly a question of the
distorted priorities that result from
the reductionist world view so in
biology it comes down to funding
eventually I mean in biology the vast
majority of funding goes to molecular
biology the medical research Council for
example used to have quite a number of
research centers that looked at medical
conditions medical outcomes it's now
been centralized at the Francis Crick
Institute in nursing pancreas station
and Francis Crick was never a doctor he
never cured anyone he was a molecular
biologist and so the whole ethos is one
of molecular medicine well that doesn't
help people who've got you know there
are lots of medical conditions where
molecular medicine is not the answer the
very fact there's a placebo effect shows
us the power of the Mind in in but the
mind is still made up of atoms the minds
are in brains which are made up of well
you see that's the reductionist and the
materialist philosophy yeah it's also
the correct uh
it's a view it's a view it's a
reductionist philosophy of nature a
materialist philosophy
um my book The Science delusion since
you mentioned it before me I if it takes
the 10 principal dogmas of Science and
looks and turns them into hypotheses
that can be questioned exactly as you
say are they refutable hypotheses no
they're not
um materialism if you say well what
would be testable materialism says the
mind's nothing but the activity of the
brain it's all inside the head what
would refute it yeah EG the existence of
telepathy which would imply thoughts
having an action and suggestions does it
refute it do materialists give up and
say oh wow we were wrong no they don't
they say this isn't evidence at all it
does it doesn't exist and it's
impossible and therefore I'm not even
going to look at yeah so the trouble is
that partha's philosophy of science is
an idealized view that assumes all
scientists are totally rational they're
not motivated by emotions or their own
beliefs they don't believe that though
scientists I know I don't believe that
scientists think like that certainly the
scientists that I know they don't well
there's one that defines this one at
this very conference Richard Dawkins who
does think like that perhaps we should
I mean dude I've had discussions with
him on these very subjects as far as
he's concerned there is no evidence
because it's impossible and therefore
the all this careful philosophy of it
could be refuted and stuff that's not
the way it works you've got a system of
belief a system of priorities and system
of careers I mean
particle physicists need more particle
accelerators they need these things to
work otherwise they won't get billions
of Euros more to fund them
it's not just a question of objectively
looking at the facts no no I know but
you know but you're bringing up sort of
values and human things and I'm sort of
interested in how how deep can we go
down down the stack of turtles and but
that's a value and a human thing I mean
it's a human it's a value when someone
makes a decision to spend billions of
Euros on one thing and nothing on
another that's a value yeah and
scientists pretend that their work is
objective but look at any Grant
application and in the first paragraph
they tell you that they're going to cure
cancer or solve the problems of the
world or cure global warming yeah all
sorts of exaggerated and basically
untrue claims that give that particular
research program a value so they can get
the money for it
it's just the way it works well it may
be the I suppose as for me sort of you
know yeah I spend my time with
Scientists they they would argue with
you they're like of course they would
they're like well
scientists all drive around in Ferraris
and they're in it for the money no
they're not in it for the money but the
many of them are in it for their careers
and jobs well there's a bandwagon effect
you know again to take a middle position
it's uh Rupert's quite right that
there's certain things people Rush After
of course because they get your Nobel
prizes or they uh
nature magazines and and what happens is
that there are various sort of thought
leaders who dominate the or that Define
the scientific agenda and so and people
rush in and they and of course there's
some sort of self-serving aspect of this
um but when I look at scientific
Endeavor over the last 200 years or so
you know by and large I approve of
what's been done uh yeah there's a man
saying there's a man at the back saying
end on a very large piece is that the
end of physics no no we get to say I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna pick
up on that poll yeah I want to go into
this next theme if I can Casey's view
okay to continue watching this video
click the link in the the top left or in
the description below or visit iai.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Art
and ideas at IAI TV